rosie what's going on i got a dui and
okay
i'm a mom so it's really weighing on me
it's just really i just can't seem
to like i feel like i'm stained or
something pretty much like
okay so how old how old are your kids
oh they're nine months and two years
nine months in two years okay
and then tell me about this dui what was
going on so
i was at a bridal shower my friend's
vital shower
apparently had too much wine
and i mean i felt like i was fine i was
like drinking water and trying to be
responsible but
hey hold on real quick let's back up so
i want to
we're going to as part of this we're
going to start changing the narrative
and it's because it's going to change
the narrative in your soul okay
so instead of saying apparently and
evidently say
i went to a bridal shower and i drank
too much
that cool i did yep and i thought i felt
fine but i wasn't
is that cool i want you to take
ownership language okay
yeah all right so tell tell me again you
had a bridal shuttle
shower and then what so i drank too much
at the bridal shower
i thought i could drive home
i ended up falling asleep at a red light
and either someone called it in to the
cops so
they pretty much one cop parked in front
of me one cop parked behind me to wake
me up that way i didn't like driving to
the intersection
and i mean from
there i had my i got taken to jail and
had
got arrested you so you you fell
you i'm smiling here not at you but with
you
you you didn't doze off you like crashed
yeah yeah so is were you did you fall
asleep because
you're you had seven drinks or did you
fall asleep because
you had just enough and you're a mom of
two little bitty kids
um i definitely do not get a lot of
sleep with the baby right
so and it wasn't like super late at
night or anything i guess that was like
hey here's a good chance to catch up on
some sleep
but obviously we're gonna catch up right
here
at uh fourth and mockingbird lane right
sounds good wow so you went to sleep to
sleep
um how far over the limit were you
um i didn't they took my blood so it
wasn't
they didn't like breathalyze me or
anything so
i'm not sure but i had to be held for at
least 12 hours
okay and you know go home
are you married yeah how was that phone
call
um well the cops called him not me i
didn't really get to talk to him until i
got out
but so paint paint the listeners a
picture of
that drive home your husband comes to
get you out of jail and you come out oh
no
i ended up getting a lift home but
oh he made you get a ride home well he
was home with the kids it was like
5 a.m so
i didn't want yeah i just luckily my
phone was still
alive i kind of wanted to take the drive
of shame by myself anyway
all right that's fair
man that would have made a christmas
story 20 years from now like hey y'all
remember the time
we wouldn't pick your mom up from jail
um so you get a lift home and you come
in
yeah he's just home with home on the
couch with the baby
but it was just kind of big we were just
trying to be quiet it wasn't much of a
conversation because of the kids
yeah but i mean later on
obviously he was upset but he he uses
also like
not understanding but calm cool and
collected
sure so here's the thing you don't have
a stain on you
okay answer answer these questions these
aren't rhetorical did you do something
dumb
yeah yeah did you put a whole bunch of
people at risk
yep you did okay was it stupid
absolutely yeah will it ever happen
again
no okay so you got
super super super lucky you didn't hurt
anybody
you got super super lucky that your two
little babies
still have a mom and
you got super super lucky that somebody
called it in and that someone didn't
smash you from behind because you were
asleep at us
at a stoplight right so cosmically you
got real lucky
and you got a husband that loves you and
was able to be there for your kids and
roll his eyes and say oh my gosh
how expensive is this going to be
um well just the lawyers right now it's
just the base pay of like
2 000. yeah it'll probably be about 10
grand by the time you get done with it
that was the last number i heard
so it's going to be real real expensive
if you're like me
you don't have 10 grand laying around so
this is going to hurt right
so if you choose to carry this around
like i'm a loser and i'm an idiot and
i've got a stain on me
then this is going to affect your kids
this is going to affect your husband
this is going to affect your friendships
and relationships
if you can stand up tall
hold your head up not use words not use
adverbs not use l-y words
apparently evidently if you say yep i
screwed up big time
and i got busted and then i went to jail
and then i paid my ten thousand dollars
in lawyers fees and court costs et
cetera
and i will never ever do that again
and it is what it is and at some point
your 10 year old is going to come
bouncing into the room mom did you ever
go to jail and you'll have to go
have a seat you know what i mean that
will be part of it
but you're not gonna shy away from it
you're not gonna lie you're not gonna be
weird about it you're gonna say yeah
your mom made a bad
dumb decision and this is why as you
noticed this is why like i do these
things right
this is why i never drink alcohol at a
friend's house this is why i don't drive
anywhere i always get an uber whatever
whatever whatever behavioral decision
you're gonna change
and then you're gonna hold your head
high and make sure this never happens
again
right yeah yeah i just yeah
anything beyond that rosie is a choice
is you choosing to hang on to this
longer than necessary
beating yourself up further doesn't help
anything
it doesn't make it not happen it doesn't
make it
um it doesn't make other people feel bad
for you
it just makes everything mush right
and it's not forgetting it it's not
undermining it it's not saying that
wasn't a big deal it's a huge deal you
got real lucky
and now we're going to move on so why
why is that hard why don't why don't you
want to choose to do that
i just see i just get these like when
i'm home and i just see the kids playing
together or something new the baby did i
just
still i get these flashbacks of you know
the jail and
just these guilty pains of like i
couldn't be here right now whether
breathing or just in a jail cell for
like multiple other reasons and so
it's just continuous like oh what a
happy moment and then
you know the the guilt the flashback
there you go okay so you ready you've
probably heard me do this on this show
but we're gonna do it again anyway i'm
gonna do it a thousand more times before
i finally get canceled you ready yeah
close your eyes real quick
okay are they closed i want you to
picture in your head
a giant um i don't know
a a green donkey
okay sitting in your front yard sitting
down not standing sitting in a weird
stance
got it okay that donkey is sitting there
and i want you to have a yellow hat on
his head
cool you got it in your head
yep all right open your eyes you just
proved to the everyone listening to this
show you can control your thoughts
so when you're sitting down playing with
your little baby
right you're two month old you're nine
month or two year old and you're nine
month old
and that thought of that freezing cold
concrete little chair bed thing right
i want you to go nope and then choose
in that moment to focus on your
two-year-old
come up with some sort of trigger which
is every time you think of jail
you reach out and grab her hand you
reach out and grab his
his little head in your hand and you
tickle it come up with some sort
and what you're doing is you are
choosing in short order
i'm not going to dwell on these things
because we are done with them
right yeah anything other than that is a
choice
and what will happen over time really in
short order
is they will stop flashing into your
mind you'll stop walking around like a
failed mother
okay you will hopefully never forget
that you endangered a whole bunch of
people including yourself
that you almost you did something dumb
enough that could have left your husband
on his own with two little kids okay why
don't you ever forget
that but the guilt and the hood and the
participation and
i'm no good i'm gonna lose we're done
with that
okay because it will only drag down
everyone around you
it'll only drag you down okay you
learned
you're gonna live and move on okay and
then you're gonna work to control your
thoughts as they pop into your head
okay thank you so much for that call i
know that's hard rosie man i'm still
dealing with crap i said when i was 14
right i see my kid and i'm like man
you're kind of dad's the dad that says
it and i go nope
not doing that man because i was 14 i
was a child
and yep i shouldn't have said that but i
did and now i'm moving on because i
don't say that anymore
right whatever the behavior happens to
be